bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france pour débattre de la situation
compliquée en guadeloupe et en
martinique
mais avant de commencer ce débat une
réaction à jean castex qui a été testé
positif aux côtés de 19 à sa fille de 11
ans l'êtes également qui a contaminé
l'autre ou pas on n'en sait rien mais
quand on entend l'exécutif dire aux
français qu'il faut respecter les gestes
barrières et et se faire vacciner et
respecter les gestes barrière malgré la
vaccination qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire cette cette photo où l'on voit
le premier ministre au congrès de la mmf
il y à il ya quelques jours victoire
jasmin dans ce contexte de négociation
justement avec la guadeloupe quelle est
votre réaction
et bien moi je voudrais qu'il soit
exemplaire qu'ils soient exemplaires
même s'il serait éventuellement un maxi
10 je ne sais pas mais on a souvent
entendu dire par des membres du
gouvernement et ministre de la santé en
particulier que même quand ont été
vaccinées on pouvait à la fois
contaminer d'autres personnes mais aussi
entre est peut être encore balade un
tommy a effectivement la maladie est bon
il l'a dit ils font en fait la
différence entre les formes graves et
tout mais c'est toujours moi je moi pour
pour moi avoir un vaccin serait être en
capacité de ne pas avoir d'avoir les
anticorps déjà et de ne pas avoir la
maladie et ne ne pas avoir non plus à
transmettre la maladie et là on n'est
pas un axe est inefficace pour lequel il
faut prendre de plus en plus de doses et
c'est quand même inquiétant ceci étant
le respect des gestes barrière doit être
la règle à la fois pour les membres du
gouvernement et pour la population s'il
y a une efficacité à saint-james warnia
je viens d'où notre réaction quand on
dit aux français qu'il faut respecter
les gestes barrières et qu'il faut se
faire vacciner charité bien ordonnée
commence par soi même selon vous pas eu
ou pas
exactement mais c'est tout le problème
avec ce et que ce gouvernement avec ce
système s'est fait ce que dis mais pas
ce que je fais ce gouvernement depuis
près de deux ans donne des leçons
morales aux français leur donne des
directives quelques fois absurde et
incohérentes il faut bien le dire on a
eu évidemment je pas revenir sur
tristement célèbre épisode des masques
des tests enfin tous les fiascos du
gouvernement qui ont émaillé la crise
sanitaire et nous allons au sein même du
gouvernement avec le premier minitre des
gens qui ne respectent pas les consignes
qu'il donne ou français voilà donc c'est
véritablement regrettable sap ou bien je
dirais part par là une nouvelle fois et
de manière éclatante oui que le le
vaccin n'est pas un rempart contre le
virus le vaccin n'est qu'un élément de
la stratégie anti qu'ovide qui
effectivement protège des forces des
formes graves mais n'empêche pas ni deux
d'être contaminés ni de transmettre le
virus donc en aucun cas il ne peut être
la panacée comme le souhaite le
gouvernement depuis le début de la
campagne de vaccination mais qui protège
des formes graves n'est pas à 100% je le
précise néanmoins l'exemplarité c'est
important d'autant que jean castex a
reçu donc les élus de guadeloupe hier
enfin par visioconférence puisqu'il
était positif au co vide il s'est
exprimé après avoir discuté justement
avec ses élus guadeloupéens l'a condamné
en dans le même temps les violences et
il a appelé à la mise en place d'une
instance de dialogue
qu'en pensez-vous à victoire jasmin on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure oui alors gt
gt1 effet prison donc il y a
effectivement cette position du
gouvernement bon la loi a été votée
personnellement j'ai défendu au moment
où il fallait le faire la non obligation
c'est à dire la vaccination mais pas
forcément une obligation ce qui est
aujourd'hui contesté d'ailleurs
certains professionnels de santé
qui sont révisés justement ceci étant il
n'y a en même temps aujourd'hui la
menace d'une éventuelle ses quais prague
dont personne ne sait vraiment si il y
aura ou pas donc on voit déjà au niveau
de l'hexagone où il y a eu dans ce
premier temps beaucoup plus de personnes
qui ont été vaccinées
on va et vient du nombre de personnes
positives donc c'est quand même
préoccupant donc je suis moi-même
professionnels de santé et ça va qu'il y
aurait éventuellement une cinquième
vague au vu de ce qui s'est passé au
mois d'août dernier on a eu des
personnes de tout âge qui sont décédés
en guadeloupe et face aux situations
catastrophiques que nous avons connues
donc moi je resterai comme et modéré les
vizirs cette instance de dialogue
concrètement ça va servir à quoi alors
cet espace de dialogue cette instance de
dialogue alors il ya d'une du niveau il
ya eu pour le stis parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont tus parts et qui
seront prises en guadeloupe à partir
d'aujourd'hui pour rencontrer des
scientifiques pour les professionnels de
santé dont un tiers des cas de figure
différents et d'après les données qui
nous ont été donnés comme moi je n'ai
pas d'espoir monsieur de les vérifier
mais il semblerait que beaucoup plus de
personnes la professionnelle de santé de
soignants se seraient fait vacciner donc
le taux est beaucoup plus important que
ce que nous avions jusqu'au mois de
septembre dernier avec les différentes
d'habitants qui ont été déplacées en
fonction de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
donc maintenant il semblerait qu'il y
ait beaucoup moins de personnes
concernées par la vaccination est
beaucoup moins donc là cette instance
serait là pour comprendre les raisons
pour lesquelles ou bien ils ne
souhaitent pas se faire vacciner ou
certains d'entre eux qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner et mais qu'ils ne
l'auraient pas encore fait en fait c'est
une instance de dialogue avec évidemment
eu des personnes les personnels
concernés et leur ordre professionnel
donc un seul stade nous avons nous avons
pu évidemment discuté avec le premier
ministre mais à l'intérieur à matignon
mais lui il n'était pas directement avec
nous dans la mesure où lui même y serait
qu'à total d'après ses dires l'un peut
donc
est même positive au moment où nous
avons
nous l'avons appris par lui-même et sa
situation
il attendait une est en attente des
résultats
confirmés
bon il a voulu la limite respecté à ce
moment là les gestes barrière
donc là je veux je veux je veux quand
même vous êtes satisfait très évolué
dans le bon sens voilà est-ce que vous
êtes satisfaite victoire jasmin d'abord
julien oudoul visiblement les
propositions de l'exécutif on l'a
entendu via le ce qu'elle dit le député
modem de guadeloupe visiblement les
propositions de l'exécutif ne sont pas
satisfaisantes pour que pour calmer la
situation réaction julien houde où là
est ce que propose jean castex
mais les mesures qui sont mis sur la
table sont dramatiquement insuffisante
dramatiquement insuffisante puisque la
crise qui aujourd'hui
éclate en guadeloupe s'est pas seulement
le résultat de la crise sanitaire c'est
le résultat de quinze ans de 20 ans
d'abandon de l'outre-mer d'abandon et de
nos compatriotes des antilles c'est ça
le résultat aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire cette veine que cette campagne
de vaccination finalement c'est
l'étincelle l'étincelle qui fait je
dirais exploser le baril de poudre mais
tout ça je dirais ça a été une
conjonction d'abandon de crise on de
mépris faut bien dire pour nos
compatriotes
de guadeloupe avec une triple crise qui
n'a jamais été résolue parce par ce
gouvernement
la guadeloupe subit depuis des années
les émanations toxiques liés aux algues
sargasse il n'y a jamais une mesure de
prises par ce gouvernement pour apporter
des solutions la guadeloupe subi la vie
chère comme dans notre mère judy où nos
compatriotes subissent une
discrimination
donc pour aller faire le plein de
courses notamment pour aller faire le
plein d'essence la guadeloupe subit
aussi je dirais une info micky et le
manque d'accès à l'eau potable
voilà il ya un français sur trois en
guadeloupe qui n'a pas accès à l'eau
potable ce qui est totalement scandaleux
et puis aussi ce scandale du chlordécone
qui a fait des ravages qui fait qu'en
guadeloupe nous avons le record du monde
malheureusement le triste record du
monde du nombre de cancers de la
prostate
voilà donc tous à conjuguer évidemment à
la crise sanitaire fait que vous avez un
ras-le-bol que vous avez une colère
alors les violences évidemment ne sont
pas acceptables et doivent être dénoncés
et les mesures toutes les mesures pour
rétablir notre l'ordre républicain
doivent être prises mais clairement il
faut s'attaquer au mal à la racine il
faut faire en sorte que nos compatriotes
en guadeloupe comme partout dans les
antilles soit respectée sont des
citoyens français et doivent être
respectées non pas avec des instances de
dialogue et non pas avec des mesurettes
pour la galerie pour la communication
mais tout simplement pour un plan de
régime a de la guadeloupe et des
antilles à la france tout simplement
pour que nos compatriotes là bas et les
mêmes droits et les mêmes chances que
les français dans l'hexagone vous parlez
d'une une situation explosive à c'est ce
qu'a dit emmanuel macron également hier
en marge d'un déplacement à amiens le
chef de l'état a demandé je cite à à ne
rien céder au mensonge et à la
manipulation par certains de cette
situation écouter
notre priorité est de continuer à
convaincre que la vaccination est la
meilleure des solutions et ne rien céder
au mensonge et à la manipulation il y à
une situation qui est très explosive
qu'il y ait un contexte très local
expliquer expliquer expliquer convaincre
convaincre convaincre parce qu'on ne
joue pas avec la santé on ne peut pas
utiliser la santé des françaises et des
français pour mener des combats
politiques
victoire jasmin manipulation de cette
situation par certains qu'en pensez vous
est-ce que président a raison
il n'y a pas de manipulation je crois
que que ce soit au cinéma et dans la vie
de tous les jours je défends les
problématiques de mon territoire que je
connais très bien il n'y a pas de
manipulation il ya une réalité c'est que
les gens ne croient plus à la parole de
l'italie particulièrement de ce
gouvernement ceci étant il ne s'agit pas
pour moi et pour mes collègues qui nous
étions tous là pour halimi trouver les
voies et moyens pour apaiser la
situation en guadeloupe et pour trouver
les meilleures solutions possibles c'est
vrai que même si les socialistes soit
satisfaisant je crois que le discours du
président de la république en plus ils
savaient très bien que nous serions reçu
par le premier ministre à notre demande
parce qu'il faut le savoir c'est nous
qui avons demandé ce rendez vous et nous
a effectivement il a accepté nous a
reçus et je crois que ça a été fait
volontairement
l'annoncent les annonces du goût du
poignet de du président de la république
et tout ce qu'il a dit sur les médias
c'était pour conditionner un petit peu
la population et pour aussi limiter les
marges de manoeuvre de deux de ses
ministres a donc là je trouve que il ne
s'agit pas pour moi de mettre du feu aux
poudres passez la situation est déjà
chaotique en guadeloupe pour plusieurs
raisons parce que les biens et les
personnes et biens ne résiste pas
malheureusement à la certes et de
certaines personnes c'est pas la
majorité il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
ont peur aujourd'hui que ce sera un des
personnages et que ce soit des habitants
des personnes qui sont limités dans
leurs alliés devenus et les soignants et
le eux-mêmes qui sont en difficulté
quand il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
contribuer à mettre le chaos donc nous
voulons tout simplement apaisé mais je
crois que l'intégralité des
problématiques qui ont été évoqués par
le sur le boul que ce soit les
problématiques de louhans fait le plein
les problématiques de saga ce sont des
choses lesquels j'ai eu l'occasion d'été
reprises à ce gouvernement et plus
encore parce que toutes les fois où il
ya il a fallu parler de l'état d'urgence
est il aussi les difficultés qu'il y
avait donc je ne m'y connais pas la
situation du territoire j'ai toujours su
me positionner quand il peut aller le
faire
aujourd'hui la situation est
suffisamment grave pour quoi je parle de
façon mesurée également parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas de mettre de l'huile sur le
feu il faut trouver les meilleures
solutions possibles donc les solutions
qui sont les propositions qui nous ont
été faites c'est sûr que ça n'a pas
forcément satisfait on peut en aucun cas
satisfait et l'ensemble des personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui en difficulté par
rapport à leur métier par rapport à leur
salaire par rapport aux conditions de
travail et par rapport à la vie tout
simplement guadeloupe il a peint que
nous voulons aussi donc je crois que le
prisons de la république
il a fini il a fait des annonces pour
l'immédiat mais il voulait aussi
conditionner les conditionner à la
famille nice mais aussi la population
donc nous qui sommes des élus à la fois
locaux mais aussi moi en tant que
parlementaire eh bien ça ne contribue
pas à nous faire respecter parce que le
problème qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
que nous nous essayons tous ensemble et
là nous nous sommes mis d'accord pour
tenter d'obtenir les meilleures
possibilités pour sortir de cette
situation chaotique mais quand on
regarde le comportement du président de
la république qui dès le matin
à
rédiger dit et je dirais eh bien ce
n'est pas fait non plus pour améliorer
les relations entre les élus que nous
sommes et notre population mais aussi
les rapports avec le gouvernement
ceci étant je souhaite vraiment que nous
puissions tous ensemble trouver les
voies et moyens pour sortir de cette
situation et c'est pour cela que les
propositions qui ont été faites même si
elles ne sont pas satisfaisantes à 100%
elles peuvent contribuer à améliorer
améliorer les relations le dialogue pour
permettre de sortir de cette situation
c'est surtout cela parce que le
président de la république lui il est à
paris il vit à paris il est venu pour
faire campagne en guadeloupe et il est
venu à sauter mon mais il ne vit pas la
famille là il était d'ailleurs en avant
avec la population ne faut-il pas
remettre cette épidémie à sa juste
mesure c'est en tout cas ce que
préconise eric zemmour qui a réagi ya
aussi à la situation en guadeloupe
regarder
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'obligation
vaccinale pourquoi obliger les soignons
à se vacciner en guadeloupe comme
partout en france
on a beaucoup joué avec la peur des gens
c'est très excessif un commentaire
julien houle dooley ce qu'on a joué avec
la peur des gens on sait le gouvernement
reste intransigeant sur cette
vaccination un
oui je pense que le gouvernement depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire
appliquer la politique du mensonge et de
la peur du mensonge puisqu'on a eu
depuis le début extrêmement de confusion
on a eu des messages totalement
contradictoire on a eu des reniements
successifs où monsieur vers ans s'est
fait le spécialiste
et puis la peur la peur a été agitée en
permanence attention vous allez voir la
troisième la quatrième et la cinquième
vague attention nous disait l'été
dernier que la rentrée allait être
épouvantable que les hôpitaux al être
engorgé que peut-être on allait voir le
spectre d'un nouveau confinement le
résultat c'est que la situation s'est
relativement bien passée le résultat
c'est que c'était qui d'amy qui devait
faire des ravages a été jugulée et le
résultat tout simplement s'est collé les
français ont été contraints de se faire
vacciner avec un pass and i ter qui en
fait des impasses vaccinale une
obligation vaccinale d'église et donc
c'est vrai que depuis le début le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu convaincre
les français mais plutôt les contraindre
au delà au delà de cette crise
économique et sociale la victoire jasmin
en guadeloupe et en martinique n'y at-il
pas non plus dans ces contestations un
problème et identitaire vous le voyez à
l'écran il y assez tract qui circule sur
les réseaux sociaux qui dénonce tout en
étalant le monopole blanc aux postes
décisionnaires notamment et qui
appellent à boycotter je cite les
magasins des békés est ce qu'il ya un
problème identitaire également en ce
moment et au oui c'est aussi cela et
l'année avant même qu'il y ait eu toutes
ces problématiques
j'ai eu l'occasion de l'annoncé
certaines pratiques par exemple au
niveau du pôle emploi en droits de
l'homme petite fille travail tant bien
que mal pour essayer de trouver des fois
c'est les moyens des formations de
mettre en cohérence en tout cas certains
besoins on se rend bien compte qu'il y a
de proximité effectivement d
certaines offres d'emploi mais il y a de
plus en plus d'entrées des entreprises
qui font directement un recrutement qui
ne passe pas par pôle emploi pour le
pôle emploi j'ai eu l'occasion le dis
donc il ya des recrutements qui se font
directement depuis paris ça à la limite
ça pourrait se faire parce que la
plupart de nos jeunes parlent pour les
études supérieures en tout cas ce qu'il
ne faut pas les études des liquides sont
parmi les tubes qui se pressent ce faire
sur le territoire au niveau de l
université des antilles parce que nous
avons ici tour de formation mais pour
cette information pour venus de
l'hexagone trois lots aline canada mais
particulièrement les jeunes qui viennent
de l'hexagone qui passent des diplômes
qui sont dans quasiment toutes les
grandes écoles maintenant et bien
quelquefois il agit 10 exemples précis
de jeunes qui sont sortis avec des
mentions qui sont sortis qu'un comprimé
majeur dans certaines fonctions et bien
quand ils arrivent ils veulent rentrer
dans leur territoire eh bien ils sont
leurs cadres et leurs supérieurs
hiérarchiques ce sont ceux qui étaient
moins bien classé que parce que au
niveau du gouvernement eh bien il ya des
réseaux et des réseaux je dirais qu'ils
font que dans certains services de
l'état il y à des personnes qui viennent
moi je dis que nous sommes sur un
territoire français dont clause là aussi
c'est notre esprit nous sommes français
mais est ce que c'est pour cela que dans
l'est certains services de l'état il n'y
a que des personnes qui viennent de
l'hexagone alors que nous avons des
personnes qui sont diplômés est de plus
en plus diplômés qui sont à la recherche
d'emploi et qui ne trouvent pas sur
notre territoire des emplois en
cohérence par rapport aux diplômes
qu'ils ont c'est pas qu'ils ne sont pas
diplômés on peut trouver des personnes
qui n'ont pas suffisamment de diplômés
on pourrait le comprendre parce que
c'est on a des diplômes qu'on ne le
retrouve pas chez les notes moi je peux
comprendre très facilement que on a
besoin des compétences des personnes qui
ont un certain niveau de connaissances
en ingénierie et tout mais dès lors que
nous avons des jeunes que les parents se
sacrifie très souvent pour payer des
études parce que ça revient à tricher en
avalisant faire des études ici parce que
ce n'est pas facile pour des parents
d'avoir de loyer d'envoi c'est une autre
chose et on l'a vu avec la crise
sanitaire dans quelle situation était
les étudiants et particulièrement des
étudiants ultramarins donc on sait très
bien que c'est très difficile et que la
plupart des jeunes veulent rentrer mais
ils ne trouvent pas d'emploi donc ils
sont contraints de rester dans
l'hexagone est encore pendante et
conflit n'aurait il pas de temps
malheureusement en cours jeudi
rapidement pour certains concours aimé
qu'on soit dans l'éducation nationale
dans la police en fait dans le pénis en
tenancière ito est bien là qu'on parle
du tri sont contre et ils sont obligés
de venir l'hexagone mais pour revenir et
bien des questions de poing des
questions de mouvement et dans
l'éducation nationale de plus en plus il
ya des personnes qui n'osent plus passer
des concours parce que ils n'arrivent
plus à rentrer chez eux alors ça c'est
le couperet sujet un vrai problème et
c'est vraiment de grandes disparités qui
existent et sa
vengeance mais j'aimerais bien que j'ai
rien pardon je vous coupe la parole
l'histoire n'est ce pas parce qu'on
arrive à l'issue de ce débat julien
oudoul un commentaire sur ce problème
identitaire final on qui à entendre guy
forget asseman rl
alors il ya véritablement des problèmes
je pense pas qu'on peut qu'on puisse les
qualifiés d' identitaire effectivement
comme aujourd'hui comme l'a très bien
dit non mais je pense qu'une très large
majorité de nos compatriotes en
guadeloupe se sentent évidemment
français sont attachés à la république
française c'est pas vraiment le débat
mais effectivement comme l'a dit très
justement madame la sénatrice le sujet
le localisme le localisme à tous les
niveaux c'est à dire faire en sorte que
la jeunesse de guadeloupe puisse
développer aussi la guadeloupe
effectivement et donc ça ça passe
évidemment par un aménagement du
territoire et par une reconfiguration
notamment en termes de formation
effectivement pour que les jeunes de
guadeloupe puis ce que ce soit se former
sur place ou quand ils ont été formés
dans l'hexagone puissent revenir et
avoir des postes à responsabilité ou en
fonction des besoins infecté locaux donc
tout ça c un vrai sujet mais finalement
ça rejoint
là la place qu'a prise les comptes qu'à
la place qui était donnée aux antilles
depuis des années qui a été il faut bien
le dire les antilles ont été abandonnés
par la république française abandonnée
non pas parce qu'on les a considéré
qu'il n'était pas français mais
abandonnée parce que les préoccupations
des gouvernements et des accès sur sur
la métropole et il est vrai que et le
nail mâcon qui a déjà eu beaucoup de mal
à constater la souffrance des gilet
jaune en bas des fenêtres de l'elysée
effectivement que la souffrance et les
difficultés de nos compatriotes à dix
mille kilomètres de paris finalement ils
ne les voient pas et ne les comprend pas
il a beaucoup de mal à les appréhender
donc le véritable problème c'est de
faire de la communauté nationale un même
bloc et que tous les français je le
redis où qu'ils se trouvent qu'ils
soient dans la ruralité au fin fond de
l'yonne par exemple qu'il soit à pointe
à pitre soient logés à la même enseigne
les mêmes droits les mêmes chances merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci d'avoir
été en direct ce matin pour répondre à
nos questions sur la crise en ce moment
aux antilles